pues sin duda se trata de una jornada de
muchísima expectación durante toda la
mañana hemos visto largas Colas en
muchas ciudades italianas también aquí
en Roma donde nos encontramos en este
momento Y esta es la primera gran
sorpresa de estos comicios que están
manteniendo en vilo a todo el viejo
continente hay que recordar que según
los últimos sondeos que se han publicado
hace dos semanas la coalición más
derechista de la historia republicana
podría tomar el poder la alternativa es
una progresista moderado se trata de
enricoleta que es el líder del partido
democrático pero sin embargo no tiene el
favor de los sondeos bueno Y usted habla
precisamente que no es favorable en las
encuestas que tantas posibilidades hay
de que la coalición de derecha forme una
coalición de gobierno
sin dudas tiene posibilidades como han
vaticinado tanto los sondeos como
también los analistas y la principal
razones que hermano Italia es el único
partido que ha permanecido fuera de
todos los últimos gobiernos que ha
habido en Italia la otra razón es que
Georgia melón y la líder de este partido
ha sabido crear una gran coalición o
junto con fuerza Italia de Silvio
berlusconi y con la liga de Mateo
sardini y esto es precisamente lo que no
ha ocurrido con el centro izquierda que
ha tenido enorme dificultades y los
partidos centristas se han negado a
integrar una gran coalición liderada por
el progresista en recoleta y que tanto
protagonismo han tenido Mateos albini y
berlusconi dentro de esta coalición de
derecha
Pues los dos han tenido bastante
protagonista protagonismo en esta
coalición pero la verdadera estrella de
toda esta campaña electoral que
recordemos ha durado apenas un mes ha
sido Georgia que atrae toda la atención
a no solo dentro de Italia sino también
fuera de Italia no hay que olvidar que
el mismo viernes la presidenta de la
comisión europea wonderline ha dicho que
Europa tiene los instrumentos si las
cosas en este país van mal y por último
en estas elecciones hay otra novedad Y
es que se aplicará un recorte al
parlamento que se aprobó en un referendo
Cuántos escaños habrá ahora
Pues sí esto es otra razón por la cual
estas elecciones son muy especiales más
de 50 millones de italianos están
convocados a votar para elegir un
parlamento recortado Qué significa esto
que solo elegirán a 600 parlamentarios
en concreto
460rán en el nuevo congreso italiano y
200 en el nuevo senado italiano Esto se
debe a una reforma de 2020 que disminuye
la representatividad de los territorios
en este hemiciclón y por supuesto Está
también es una incógnita es una
incógnita el efecto las consecuencias
que tendrá sobre estas elecciones que
como decíamos mantienen la atención alta
de toda la Unión Europea